hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled comprehensive landscape of the
tumor micro environment
analyzed with scitov technology i am
antonina salcido of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by fluidime
now let's get started before we begin
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
i now present today's speaker dr
hirayoshi nishikawa
a professor at the national cancer
center in japan
for a complete biography on dr nishikawa
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr nishikawa you may now begin your
presentation
hello i am yoshinishikawa from national
cancer center japan and nagoya
university
in nagoya city in japan
so today i'd like to talk about the site
of technology for the
comprehensive analysis of tumor micro
environment
this is my coi
today's my talk have a two parts first
i'd like to
quickly summalize the calendar status of
cancer therapy
and then go to their how we can use a
site of technology for the cancer
immunotherapy analysis
i'd like to start my talk with a quick
resume a quick summary of the cancer
immunotherapy
upon the clinical application of cancer
immunotherapy
so cancer immunology
accumulate much attention as you can see
here
as you see as you see on the left side
of
this slide a big journal nature science
uh
published a lot of cancer immunology
paper
and also in 2018
dr eisen and dr hunger received their
nobel prize
then of course i didn't know cancer
immunotherapy
was applied in the clinic as a false
treatment
of cancer but now as you see
in the right side of this flight
cancer immunotherapy was now combined
with
[Music]
various cancer immunotherapies such as
radiotherapy
and in target cell molecular target
therapy
and chemotherapy and immunotherapy so
now
immunocircuit comes the center of cancer
therapy
but this concept using
immune system for the cancer therapy
studied with almost 100 years ago
as a hypothe as a hypothesis
over cancer immune surveillance as areas
99 poor air is postulated that
cancers occur spontaneously in people
and the immune system is able to
recognize
and protect against it and
50 years later this thomas and macbonnet
introduced a theory of cancer myosidelas
the theory states that cancerous
surveillance is their
physiologic function of the immune
system cancerous cells are recognized as
foreign and
that can be constantly eliminated
by cancer immunosurveillance
but based on this
theory we have questions why
immune competent hearts
develop cancer then
now bob schreiber and
dr lloyd old provide a new concept
cancer immuno editing in this concept
interaction between the cancer
development
and in the immune system are divided in
three phases
normal cells exposed to various
stimulation
during our life for example ultraviolet
and some reagent a cancerous reagent
then abnormal cells are developed but
these
cancer cells are eliminated from the
host
by the immune say by the immune cell
immune by the immune system
so this phase is called elimination
phase
but meanwhile cancer cells
get the several mutations
and also reduce the immunogenic antigen
then go into the phase
called equilibrium in this phase cancer
cells
try to avoid their attack from the
immune system
by reducing antigenic molecules
such as the gene alterations and also
provide
i induce our gene alteration into the
immune associated molecule
such as msc class 1 and interferon gamma
receptor
then elastigenic cancer cells are
selected
during this phase in addition
cancers try to recruit immunosuppressive
cells in the tumor their tumor micro
environment
then finally developed as a clinically
apparent cancer
the last phase of the state is called
escape weight
then less immunogenic a lot of
[Music]
immune immunosuppressive cells in the
microenvironment are developed
in cancer patients
for example
mhd craftsman depletion and their
molecule deductions are the major part
of this immune selection part
found in in the equilibrium phase
that this these three phases are not
equally
happened in each cancer patient each
cancer patient has
some way some balance for example some
patients had a
high balance on equilibrium phase and
some has a high on the rest eating
escape
part then generally cancer patients
have a various types of
phenotypes in their own in their
tumor micro environment for example the
patient
have a high a patient cancer have high
uh
balance on their immune escape phase you
may see
the right and right side of this light a
lot of
immune cells shown in the ammunition
chemistry
were detected in the tumor micro
environment and these in
call types are called immune
immunologically hot tumors
and easy to respond to their
immunotherapy but
in some cases the rest immunogenic cells
are selected and in that case
almost no immune cells are infiltrated
in the tumor micro
environment these types you may see on
the left slide and left side of this
slide
so in this type of cancer
it is difficult to get clinical
responses by cancer immunotherapy alone
so we need to consider combination
therapy with cancer immunotherapy plus
some other kind of cancer therapy so
then
we need to develop the biomarker
biomarker
other optimized for developing optimized
cancer immunotherapy
to this end site of technology
have much advantage
uh compared to previous uh for cytometry
and other technology because aside from
using cytos technology
we can analyze the more than 30 40
molecules at once
first i would like to introduce our
experiences of using the perforabrad
so we collected them free and paused
peripheral blood samples
from a full patient who showed a
clinical response and
to show the clinical response and other
two
unfortunately failed to show clinical
responses
then we analyze the peripheral breath
using the site of as you see the bottom
of this white
so the uh
peripheral blood lymphocyte and other
monocytes and are anal were
beautifully detected using site of
analysis
uh center center of the disney
product on the on the left side or
bottom other
are the t cells and detected by cd3 and
top of the center is the cd8 and bottom
is the
orange part is the cd4 t cells
as you see this figure so you may
dissect either population each
population of
immune cells then we compare them free
and post samples and between the
responder and non-responder patient
then you may easily detect the big
differences in particularly the cd4 part
in the cd4 reduction of cd4
part in non-responder patient in the
post samples
you may see in the left side of this
slide
so cd4 t cells are clearly reduced
then we go into the depths of this
population using their spade analysis
then we found three and
uh showed a big change
between a big difference show the big
differences between the
um responder and lonely sponsored
patient
then analyze the detail molecular
expression
using this heat map analysis
then we found cd27 positive fast
positive cd4 positive central memory t
cells increase is exclusively detected
responder patient
but not in the non-responded patient
this change
is a strictly uh show the importance of
the central uh clearly showed the
importance of the
relatively
young juvenile t cells
increase is a very important factor
for the pd1 blockade therapy
we and then uh confirmed this change
using the uh validation cohort
as you see here here here see here
uh led right uh clearly the
uh increase clear increase of the this
t-cell phenotypes are detected in the
responder in evening another cohort
so they're using their site of
technology
and we can detect the important change
of the t-cell fraction in responder
patient
so the cd for t-cell fraction a part of
g-cell
cd4 t-cell fraction is a very important
uh for their clinical responses
of pwm broccoli therapy
in addition site of technology can be
available for analyzing a tumor
tumor microenvironment because
we may you may think the
lymphocyte much less
number of lymphocytes are available from
the tumor micro environment
but even though such tiny amount of
tumor tissues
so we can analyze the details using the
site of analysis
so we focus on the regulatory t cells i
quickly introduce allegra to t cells
these
t sub t cells are identified by dr
shimon sakaguchi
my previous boss and also my mentor
and these cells are developed in the
thymus
particularly the high tcr affinity
against self-component
are generally deleted
in the thymus but if these cells gain
the expression of fox p3
these cell can be survived as the
immunosuppressive
regulatory t cell then these cell types
have a very uh
various kind of immunosuppressive
machineries
for example they suppress uh
antigen-presenting cells through ctl for
expression
in addition they consume a lot of cd2
and a lot of il2
through the expression higher expression
of cd25
and also they produce immune suppressive
cytokines such as tgf better and il-10
so t-rex cells has various style various
kinds of immune suppressive machineries
to inhibit the uh the activation of
affected t-cells
therefore the high numbers of t-rex cell
regulatory t-cells in the tumors
are generally associated poor prognosis
in cancer patients but also
we have to consider why t-rex cells are
recruited in the tumor micro environment
on the left side of this left side of
this slide
you can see the
these regulatory t-cells are generally
accompanied with the cda t-cell infrared
infiltration
so regulatory t cells uh have a
expression of the master trans
transcription factor fox p3 but uh this
uh when we identified a fox specific
expression
in the tumors generally ob also
identified a high
infiltration of cd8 t cells that means
the cda t
cell induces inflammation to stop such
information twx cells are recruited to
the tumor micro environment
so the two block uh such
inflammation uh so the t-rex cells
uh act as an immune suppressor but of
course in the tumors
we to to reduce or depre-eliminate
tirax cells important factor to gain
strong anti-tumor immune responses on
light side of this slide
you may see the some kind of keurig
a t-rex targeted therapy
but still we are
on the way for finding the best way to
control the t-rex cells in the tumor
in the tumor immunology
so you based on this this data
we try to analyze the details
of our patient who received their
[Music]
pd-1 blockade therapy then we focus on
the non-small cell lung cancer patient
in in asian countries east asian
countries
so half of their about half of the
non-small cell language
lung cancer have an egfr mutation
unfortunately these egfr mutated
non-small cell lung cancer are resistant
to the pwm blockage therapy as you see
here
so we need to find why
is if a mutated non-small cell lung
cancer are resistant to can
cancer immunotherapy particularly pedium
broccoli therapy
to identify to clarify this resistant
mechanism
we first analyze the gene alteration in
japanese cohort and tcga and tcga
data the data set top is
our japanese cohort and the bottom is
the
tcga data set as you see here
on the left side so generally egfl
mutated cancer has much less
gene alteration compared to egfl wild
type
because the egfr mutation is a very
strong
driver mutation to induce
cancer development so that's why the one
easy of a mutation is good enough for
the corrosion genesis
that and then the
other passenger mutations
are reduced of course
then there and that means there
less uh gene alteration numbers induce a
less immunity in
immune responses that is associated with
that was analyzed by as you as arrested
by the gene
expression pattern uh on the right side
when we analyze the gene expression in
the tumor micro environment
so the uh the almost all
immunoassociated gene expression is much
less in the
egfr mutated cancer based on
this this gene expression data we
analyze
in depth of the immune cell infiltration
and the molecular expression by in the
tumor micro environment
by cyto so the we
they're using their tiny biopsy samples
we can analyze the cyto
acid so as you see here pop is the dj
for mutated cancer
bottom is the edge of a wire type cancer
as you see here
cd8 infiltration is much higher in egypt
for wild type cancer
and in addition these cd8 t cells
have expression of pd-1 that means that
pd-1 blockade
should inhibit their exertion and then
gain the higher activation of
the dcda t cells in egfl wild type
cancer compared to easier mutated cancer
into another interesting point is here
on the purple cycle so teleconfiguration
as we mentioned generally telex cells
are
recruited by the inflammation induced by
cda t-cell in the tumor micro
environment
in this case eg for wild-type cancer
should contain
higher frequencies of t-rex cells
compared to easier for mutated cancer
but you can see almost the comparable
frequencies of
fox p3 expressing t-rex cells are
detected
in egfl mutated and ej for wild-type
cancer
that means they're probably easy for
mutated cancer have some
some machine mechanism to recruit
t-rex cells
then we found an interesting downstream
signaling of egfr
you can see the center of this slide jnk
and akt signaling
so i summalize the part so actually it's
easy for signaling
and provide a very important aspect
against the immune system first the easy
for signaling provider
akt signaling then stop the
transcription of irf1 and then down
regulate the cxcl10 and ccl5
resulting the reduction of ctr
infiltration to the tumor micro
environment
on the other hand jnk stimulate ap1
and produce a ccl22
ccl22 recruit the ccr4 expressing t-rex
cells in the tumor micro environment
that means they're easier for signaling
directly control
the t-rex of infiltration
and also stop the infiltration of ctls
of course by
our tki signaturing t-regul infiltration
was
clearly downright rated in addition
using any models we analyzed a possible
combination therapy with anti-pd1
therapy
and their egfl tki as you see here
on the blue line clearly the combination
therapy
is showed a much better anti-tumor
effect and elongation
of survival compared to either treatment
alone
and or control groups that mean they're
based on the site of analysis we found a
new
concept of the combination therapy in
egfl mutated cancers
and in egypt her tki jnk signaling the
stop
and the t regular filtration that down
regulated and on the other hand
akt
was activated and
ctl infiltration was augmented that
means the clearly that we can change the
tumor micro environment
more immune prone microenvironment to
activate
their antitumor immune responses in
addition to that
we also have our experience about
[Music]
hyperion analysis hyperion site of
analysis
using their
[Music]
pathological sections
so we first analyzed their
bitter tracked cancer tissues
because the biliary tract cancers is
difficult to
uh apply a disco to
treat with immune cancer immunotherapy
then we
focus on the why these cancers are
difficult to treat with
cancer immunotherapy first we analyzed
and
collected the tumor tissues
and analyzed immune cell infiltration
with immunohis chemistry
as you see here two available cancer and
have a possessed much higher frequencies
of
t cells compared to two known available
cancers
two available two known available is
just only depending
on the cell numbers from the same size
of uh biopsy as tumor tissues
so clearly the high tissue infiltration
is associated
with better prognosis uh inspired by
meteorology track cancers so
this t-cell filtration is clearly
associated with
early stage cancer as you see on the
left side and left side of this slide
and in addition
to tumor diameter less than 50
millimeter
it contains a large number of g-cell
filtration
and interestingly pd1 positive cd8
positivities of infiltration
is
[Music]
totally different in their
tumor size so high pd1 infiltration was
associated the less
as a small tumor size
then we applied these samples to the
hyperion assay this acid
we can analyze more than 20 molecules uh
with uh from pathological sections
then we found as you see here on the red
and
green staining so high
cda2 infiltrations were detected
at height cda t cell expressing pd-1
was detected in the just adjacent to the
tumor tissues
this is just a big
differences compared to the tumor
tissues
less two minute filters these of
infiltration
industrial infiltration tumors we cannot
detect such
[Music]
lymphocytes around the two tumor tissues
so clearly that these hyperion acids we
can analyze
the high t cell filtration not only the
tissue filtration
also they're detailed markers of t-cell
infiltration
in this case we focus on the pd-1
because
this time i don't have enough time to
experience it explain
to explain their uh pd1 expressing cda t
cells but generally pd1 expressing cda t
cells are exposed to the tumor antenna
that means the p21 expressing
[Music]
cdat cell adjacent to two more means
that these
t cells are activated by two more
than two more antidotes then those
g t cells should attack uh
to the tumors by inhibiting
by using pd1 brochure therapy
clearly we are now analyzing these
another lung cancer tissues and the pd-1
high pd-1 expressing cda t-cell
infiltration is
associated with the favorable prognosis
after pdf rocket therapy so
now we can analyze the very wide
uh broader numbers over antigen uh
problem and the
number of molecules on the on the cda t
cell
and also there are another important of
importance
is the localization of these tumor
antigen specific t cells
uh site of hyperion assay can analyze
both such
broad and broad numbers of insulin
and molecules and also the localization
of the cells then we can
find the new biomarkers using this
noble technique and not the site of
techniques
so i introduced
our site of technology for the cancer
immunotherapy
acid so i hope
[Music]
we continue to analyze the tumor tissues
and peripheral blood
using these uh very developed
technologies
and identified a more
[Music]
sophisticated biomarkers
so today's studies was done in national
cancer center
and also nagoya university and with
many collaborators thank you very much
for your attention i'm happy to take
your questions
thank you dr nishikawa for that
informative presentation
unfortunately dr nishikawa could not
join us for the live q a
however questions submitted during the
time of his presentation
and those during the on-demand period
will be addressed by dr nishikawa via
the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july of 2021
until next time goodbye